[Musique]
perdu au milieu du pacifique des
époustouflant paysage de la nouvelle
calédonie un petit coin de paradis
sur la côte ouest le lagon de pau et sa
palette de turquoise face à lui le rêve
de nemo un camping familial à la vue
imprenable
le patron c'est bruno il y a trente ans
il a eu un coup de coeur pour l'endroit
[Musique]
après avoir tenu des maisons d'hôtes à
marseille il s'est finalement installé
ici il ya six ans
ça me fera 3000 francs s'il vous plaît
en nouvelle calédonie on compte en
francs pacifique pour passer des nuits
ici
ce jeune couple avec enfant devra payer
10 euros par personne et par nuit donc
le snack ouvrent à 8h le matin
oui c'est plus tout à fait ça maintenant
on se donne une heure de fermeture qui
est 23h
et votre emplacement est ici alors la
délimitation est simple vous avez la
barrière d'un côté et vous avez les deux
arbres à vous
sachez que le soleil levant il est de ce
côté donc
bonne installation
il ya six ans quand bruno se lance il
loue le terrain pour 19 ans à l'époque
il ne sait pas trop dans quelle aventure
il s'engage enfin que c'était une vraie
jungle une route il y avait des armes
qui étaient à plus de trois mètres de
hauteur qu'il a fallu attendre le
passage d'un tracteur pour me défricher
le plus gros et me rendre compte
vraiment de la vue à partir de là j'ai
décidé où j'allais implanter la
structure du snack où j'allais mettre
les campeurs
pour ambre et sa petite nahla c'est le
baptême du feu
et je pensais qu'on pouvait elle a
ajouté qu'elle a l'excusé trajectoire
au même moment une famille kanak prend
ses quartiers
voilà
c'est chouette hein avec ses cinq
enfants elle a choisi l'autre formule
proposée par bruno détente déjà tout
équipé ici vous avez
nelly temps dans cette chambre là et
vous allez délitant ici et vous avez
voilà vous avez 1 2 3 4 litres avec les
sacs de couchage
voilà
des plaisirs simples pour un camping où
les jours s'écoule paisiblement
la seule nuisance sonore bien des
coulisses greg 41 ans le fils de bruno
s'activent sur le gros chantier du
moment c'est le la confection d'un bloc
sanitaire
pour remplacer celui qui est ici
donc on fait tout en moi parce que c'est
moins cher fait tout nous-mêmes parce
que c'est moins cher
s'il y aura trois cabinets de toilette
de 3 lier à de pissotière s'il y aura un
espace table à langer beaucoup de
familles et ça a été une demande des
mamans d'avoir un petit espace pour
pouvoir changer les enfants donc on va
rajouter un espace table à langer ici
greg s'affairent sous les yeux de sa
compagne emma depuis deux ans ils sont
en nouvelle calédonie pour prêter main
forte à bruno
et ma chère tout ce qui est partie snack
accueil
soirée-concert campine
moi je suis plutôt planquer on va dire
et elle allait plus en face des clients
moi je suis plutôt l'homme de long
chacun son rôle ancienne enseignante et
mattia la réception
depuis deux ans il lui a fallu apprendre
à travailler aux côtés de son beau père
bruno parfois c'est très sympa et
parfois c'est de fait compliqué non sa
famille
les avantages forcément famille on se
dit un peu plus facilement les choses
c'est peut-être un peu plus fluide mais
les inconvénients c'est que on vit
ensemble on travaille ensemble on parle
boulot sans arrêt donc on et ça chacun
reste chez soi et que on se sépare et
parfois à 60 ans et une santé fragile
bruno a choisi de lever le pied la
succession est assurée
et
c c'est quelque part inespéré mais
mais voilà c'est arrivé c'est chouette
chouette pourvu que ça dure vous allez
soit cette table ici
l'essentiel du chiffre d'affaires c'est
le restaurant qu'il réalise à table des
campeurs mais surtout une clientèle
locale ou de passage attirés par les
spécialités du gesvres
[Musique]
c'est l'accord est une épopée avec des
crevettes ici de l'assaut
coucou quand même
[Musique]
une centaine de couverts par jour pour
un restaurant ouvert toute l'année
pour répondre à la demande la cuisine va
très bientôt s'agrandir
questions d'intendance et gestion des
stocks c'était ma qui s'y connaissent
des courses ah oui la jurade sur 1000 à
faire les courses mais un quart d'heure
dans un sens
emma seront à bourail la ville la plus
proche du camping en pleine brousse
originaire de toulouse emma est tombé
sous le charme de la région est très
nature
donc
voilà c'est vraiment la nature face à
l'océan
et l'organisation dont elle a besoin au
quotidien ça s'apprend
moins exotique l'arrivée sur le parking
du seul supermarché à des dizaines de
kilomètres à la ronde
[Musique]
en nouvelle calédonie ce qui change
aussi ce sont les prix
très cher en moyenne 30 % de plus qu'en
france pour tous même les produits de
première nécessité donc ça aussi on
s'adapte on trouve des alternatives
et poids malienne de tu crois nouvelle
zélande australie est-ce qu'on est loin
de tout faire venir les la matière
première problème depuis l'europe donc
tout coûte cher tout coûte cher et dans
les rayons certains produits se font
rares un exemple de rupture on a besoin
de neuf pour la cuisine le rayon évident
donc il va falloir qu'on reparte au
centre du village pour aller tenter de
trouver des oeufs sinon les desserts
vont être compliqués à faire
ça fait à peu près
78,7 mérite pour venir et sur place font
et vivent
malgré les dix sept mille kilomètres qui
séparent l'île de la france emma n'a pas
hésité à quitter son emploi
d'enseignante pour vivre cette aventure
au milieu du camping la maison familiale
bruno et greg long construite ensemble
année dernière non non non et encore non
non non pas encore pas encore fait de
toile et de bois la maison a été conçue
pour s'intégrer dans le décor peut-être
un peu
c'est le projet d'avoir quand même enfin
ma maison ici sur le terrain et puis
pour pas dénaturer avec le camping avec
le snack où tout est en bois je voulais
pas du tout d'une maison en dur
traditionnel mais je me sentais pas trop
de vivre à l'année dans une tente donc
on a utilisé la structure extérieure et
puis grégory s'est chargé de toute la
construction des murs et des cloisons à
l'intérieur
depuis que bruno a pris du recul c'est
aujourd'hui greg emma qui habitent ici
le salon
ouvert sur la cuisine pour des questions
de praticité de convivialité là on a
notre poste d'observation sur le snack à
la salle ça nous permet de pouvoir
gaieté même si on n'est pas là haut sur
place pour voir comment ça se passe si
on a du monde etc c'est toujours sympa
de voir jeter un oeil et ici on a un
parti suite parentale comme on aime bien
dire en métropole avec une une chambre
toujours simple c'est de la déconne
naturel avec de la récup
et le luxe c'est la clim effectivement
certaines certains après-midi pour faire
la sieste c'est très agréable est venu
ici on a là la salle de bain avec la
douche lavabo la machine à laver et puis
un petit dressing mais c'est un petit
peu le bazar donc je vais pas trop vous
le montrer pour soixante dix mille euros
aménagement compris une jolie petite
maison à moindre coût
ce jour là bruno réalise un rêve vieux
de trente ans un baptême de l'air en ulm
pour survoler son la grille
[Musique]
pour la première fois de sa vie
bruno découvre son lagon vue du ciel
300 km de barrières tout autour de la
crise et en fin de compte on est le plus
grand
assez fermé incroyablement beau dire que
d'habitude a relaté à 1500 pieds ça
correspond à 500 mètres à peu près
d'accord
cet arrière ouais gilberte ça ressemble
à un requin sa voix magique que liszt et
l'oeil la barre il ya combineront lie à
toutes formes et effacer ça bouge ah oui
l'histoire électorale de m on dirait
vraiment eu cette heure aucun travail
c'est cool jazz à hauteur d'homme
siemens mais lââm et en os
voilà ton lahlou mr bruneau quand tu
évolues pour monter ton complice est
impressionnant me dire
que s'y prennent tôt et que tu meures
pareil
maintenant j'apprends plein des durs
[Musique]
sur la plage du camping de peau et une
famille vient de débarquer
il ya dix ans sylvain et corinne ont
quitté paris pour le bout du monde
aujourd'hui ils tiennent un salon de
coiffure à nouméa la capitale ils ont
deux enfants nolan 12 ans et son petit
frère tao deux ans le petit dernier est
né sur les vacances annuelles
et pris 15 jours pour être avec mes
enfants ces paradis je vais aller à la
barrière
quand le vent se lève le lagon de pau et
devient le terrain de jeu préféré des
kitesurfeurs
pour premières loges la petite famille
profite du spectacle
votre entretien
allez
une habitude là des petits mickeys récit
par ci par là pour la tps quoi ça ça
nous des temps presse oui on a un super
belles couleurs il ta g
c'est agréable pour
il
après une heure passée sur l'eau
sylvain n'a plus qu'à enjamber la dune
pour rentrer davantage ici c'est de
passer la voile directement dit d'abord
aux cantons
est ce que dans ma toile il est 6h
presse met au propre et préparer
barbecue
aller
pendant deux semaines la famille va
vivre sous tente
visites guidées assurées par corinne
donc là on a
donc c'est là que nous on dort et non
face il ya de petits seins comme ça on
peut l'entendre on a mis son hip a
rappelé pour que ce soit plus facile
puis
petite cuisine à peu près rangé e
coleman ici et gamelles
et cette année grande première pour
nolan
à 12 ans il dort désormais seul comme un
grand
devenu expert en la matière corinne et
sylvain ont découvert le camping grand
départ qu'en nouvelle calédonie a
travaillé dur à paris et à c'était pour
ça on avait
essayé à partir
les hôtels
à l'étranger mais au soleil
sait on a un pays authentique donc en
fait c'est retrouver l'authenticité de
d'avant se prend pas la tête en fait
le rêve de nemo un camping en toute
simplicité de la douche à la cuisine la
vie en plein air
[Musique]
surtout pour les enfants et de manger
comme les fruits sont les salles impulse
une fin de journée dans la douceur
calédoniennes il fait encore 25 degrés
et avant le service du soir
[Musique]
un petit moment de détente pour emma et
les sept employés du camping pour
sylvain et sa famille au menu ce soir
des coudes à nyon
ont fait pas qu'elles arrivent
les mouvements
[Musique]
depuis un mois la famille camping s'est
encore élargie pour la haute saison emma
a reçu le renfort de ses parents manuel
et véronique lui et éducateurs l
infirmière près de narbonne ils se sont
mis en disponibilité pour travailler
deux mois aux côtés de leur fille
véronique n'oublie pas pour autant que
de profiter des plaisirs de l'île
pêcheur local et qui vont être donc
griller sur un barbecue sur la terrasse
c'est d'être produit qui valait courant
d'un petit peu cher même ici et qui
valent quand même beaucoup moins cher
comment et quand on peut en profiter en
profite
le plaisir de la bonne chère le plaisir
surtout pour emma de retrouver enfin ses
parents elle ne les avait pas vus depuis
deux ans
ferme avec la distance et l'éloignement
les proches on les a via les écrans
heureusement que ça existe de nos jours
quand même mais mais forcément il ya un
manque donc là je me suis dit autant
faire d'une pierre deux coups et les
embauchés pour le service et bricolage
et puis les avoir avec moi tout l'été
ici cette expérience deux mois et demi
au précédent femmes alors que la vie
dans le vie par procuration avec des
épreuves avec des téléphones c'est
quelque chose de textes anciens même si
c'est difficile même si on transpire
même cas de
fraude commise entre salariés
le patron il vigile à gratter avec sa
maman parce que tu rêves et puis après
on aurait pu enlever les fonds locaux
furent ben non je contenir de nomination
il a fallu surtout former mais ronnie
kla au maniement de la caisse
est vite rentrée oui oui on a connu pire
[Rires]
cet endroit restera dans mon coeur mais
leurs partants et je sais pas si en
europe a dû intervenir
c'est magique
bien entouré bruno peut désormais
envisager l'avenir sereinement au moment
où ils sont arrivés en plus c'est devenu
vital quoi je prêt
plus faire sans des gens de l'entière
confiance soit en fait et il y avait que
mon fils ma belle victoire faire ça et
là c'était vraiment c'était ça ou je
vendais que je pouvais faire ça tout
seul et la paire continue à tourner les
retours sont toujours aussi excellent
donc c'est la preuve que sa perte ça
continue dans ce que lorsque j'ai créé
et c'était le but quoi je vais monter
quelque chose de nous ce n'était pas
notre but de le descendre au contraire
une volonté de le faire progresser
de change et peut-être quelques règles
de m'imposer d'autres pour faire avancer
la société après tout ça
c'est la fin du déjeuner aussi pour le
petit à eau qui s'offrent une sieste
bien calée au creux d'un banyan
pendant ce temps là pour ses parents et
son grand frère un classique du camping
la corvée de vaisselle après c'est
chacun son tour
[Musique]
pour ses vraies vacances au programme
cet après midi on va voir les poissons
une sortie sur le lagon est tortueux
deux heures de balade à bord d'un bateau
à fond de verre l'idéal pour profiter au
mieux de la beauté sous marine bientôt
holmes
de la boe petty km de long sur 12 mois
dollars tous en selle en réserve
naturelle n'a pas le droit de pêcher
honneur
et on est au milieu du classement à
l'unesco la zone des coraux
particulièrement bien préservé
la l'oreiller bas
rhinois
les bretons titao à deux ans le clou du
spectacle c'est maintenant il tente
verte
pour ce moment-là l'inconnu bah oui de
voir ça son élimination là c'est autre
chose
[Musique]
partis le charme du lagon aujourd'hui
bruno ne va pas en profiter
c'est un grand jour pour le conflit
le voilà
bonjour voilà l'entrée donc je transcris
comment ça devrait passer à l'arrière du
camion la nouvelle cuisine du restaurant
[Musique]
c'est un soulagement se soit passé et
puis puisse le mettre là et faire
un algeco de 15 mètres carrés pour
remplacer agrandir la cuisine
vieillissante accord encore un petit peu
ah bon j'ai posé
on sent le professionnalisme la
voilà mot bravo ouais
ça c'est la nouvelle cuisine oui
oui complètement là c'est tout à fait ça
ça c'est le pass pour forcer à venir en
salle
puisque tout l'arrière va être
transformée maintenant tout est modifié
forcément
[Musique]
formé
dans une dizaine de jours la nouvelle
cuisine devrait être opérationnel ce
sera bientôt aussi le tour du nouveau
bloc sanitaire
le rêve de nemo continue de grandir
[Musique]
de quoi fidéliser un peu plus les
habitués du camping
regarde moi
mais là à commencer par silva ans
corinne et lors du
web